notre invité politique ce matin c'est le
président du groupe union centriste au
sénat et marseille bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale ont représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
mais ces scènes bonjour on commence
évidemment on en vient d'entendre jean
castex 1 par le débat qui s'est tenu
hier au sénat le sénat qui a donc
largement approuvé la tenue des
régionales et des départementales et
vent et 27 juin prochains un décalage
d'une semaine
est-ce que vous avez vu dans ce décalage
de la part de l'exécutif de la politique
où c'est uniquement une question
sanitaire
je sais plus quoi dire à propos de ces
c'est bon ça fait un an qu'on a voté la
date du mois de juin enfin je veux dire
il ya eu le rapport debré donc à la
suite du rapport debré y avait consensus
pour dire ok on reporte ses élections au
mois de juin tant que les élections
étaient fixées au mois de juin là on
nous a demandé de revoter pour être sûr
qu'ils auraient même mois de juin
d'accord on a consulté à peu près tout
le monde jusqu'à temps d'avoir la bonne
réponse
moi je propose quand même que maintenant
on fasse une convention citoyenne on va
tirer quatre ou cinq gars au sort pas
demander s'ils sont vraiment sûr qu'il
faut vraiment faire ça au mois de juin
cela dit monsieur marcel gili avait
l'oeil et le rapport du conseil
scientifique est tombé entre les deux il
y avait quand même des incertitudes est
ce qu'à un moment donné vous n'êtes pas
posé la question vous même de reporter
ces élections une fois de plus pour les
faire dans un contexte plus apaisée à
l'automne comme le demandaient certains
certains élus pour une campagne plus
apaisée et peut-être en oeuvre un taux
de participation plus élevée pour
d'abord les élections normalement
devaient et auront lieu au mois de juin
il est toujours possible de voir une
clause de revoyure ou un rapport d'étape
fin mai en cas de
épidémie virulente donc à tout moment
dans ce domaine comme dans d'autres on
peut arrêter un processus pour dire
qu'il faut reporter deuxièmement il ya
quand même un calendrier contraint vous
avez les élections présidentielles mois
de mai de l'année prochaine et donc
c'est pas très grand public mais enfin
il ya des problèmes de comptes de
campagne il ya des problèmes de campagne
on sait pas s'il va y avoir un
référendum parce qu'entre les deux
j'avais oublié on nous dit qu'il
pourrait peut-être y avoir un phenom sur
le climat bon voilà donc et il faut
quand même case et tout ça et donc les
élections c'est important c'est un
problème de légitimité démocratique en
plus les régions jouent un rôle
important pour ce qui est de la relance
économique
et je pense qu'on en a besoin aussi donc
à un moment donné il faut bien qu'on
respecte les échéances vous êtes
rassurés par les protocoles sanitaires
et les mesures qui ont été décidées pour
favoriser le scrutin écoutez dans ce
domaine là aussi comme dans d'autres on
fait passer le bac fait passer toutes
sortes d'examens y la vie continue donc
il ya des protocoles dans la vie
quotidienne
je crois que les français les françaises
ont fait se plie la plupart du temps ces
protocoles quand ils prennent les
transports en commun quand ils vont dans
leur entreprise donc voter c'est pas
vraiment le sujet parce qu'il ya
rarement beaucoup de monde dans un
bureau de vote
la difficulté c'est quand on fait le
dépouillement le soir il faut éviter de
s'agglutiner et puis la campagne bat
écoutée elle sera ce qu'elle sera c'est
évident qui aura pas de grand meeting
qui aura pas de grandes réunions mais il
y aura plus tôt une nouvelle forme de
campagne plus moderne avec les réseaux
sociaux est suffisamment préparé
suffisamment anticipé par l'exécutif
pour vous ben je sais pas si l'exécutif
l'a anticipé en tous les cas les
candidats eux l'ont anticipée parce que
ça fait quand même des mois qui se met
dans la situation de devoir faire
campagne avec des contraintes
particulières donc l'inventivité va
rapidement être manifeste et on va voir
que les candidats sont capables de
s'adapter non
l'inventivité elle devrait pas aussi
mener la réflexion sur le vote par
internet on n'a pas bon de tino une
occasion de développer ce vote à cette
occasion va écouter jusqu'à présent il
faut dire que la plupart des formations
politiques dans ce pays et des plutôt
opposés à la mise en place du numérique
dans les élections
chaque année moi j'étais rapporteur
quand j'étais à la commission des
finances de ce dossier ça fait plusieurs
années que le ministère de l'intérieur
dit chaque année la propagande
électorale on va là numérisés ça permet
de gagner en gros 350 millions donc
chaque année vous pouvez regarder à
l'assemblée au cnra toutes les parties
politiques tous les partis politiques
sans exception s'y opposent non c'est
pas le moment parce qu'il ya des zones
blanches parce que les personnes âgées
parce qu'il ya des gens qui manipulent
loin de tout ça on y viendra c'est
peut-être l'occasion
mais c'est vrai que il ya une volonté
d'aller vers le numérique on le fait
pour un tas de services publics la
sécurité sociale pour l'emploi etc
on va y venir je pense que ce sera
peut-être une opportunité avec cette
crise pour que l'on passe davantage au
numérique dans la vie publique mais pas
pour cette élection là peut-être pour la
présidentielle on s'est probablement
c'est trop tôt on peut pas faire ça
n'importe comment à parler de la
campagne en ile de france
oui comment comment vous sentez la
campagne de valérie pécresse et
et accessoirement aussi est ce que vous
vous verriez bien valérie pécresse mener
une campagne aussi pour une élection
dites-moi télé j'en sais rien je suis
très confiant en tous les cas quand je
vois comment sûr nous nous sommes dans
la majorité de valérie pécresse et nous
allons
travailler avec elle pour cette campagne
bon nous sommes très confiants et quand
on voit les premiers chiffres on voit
que son bilan est positif qu'elle a
beaucoup travaillé et que visiblement
les franciliens le reconnaissent donc
une élection n'est jamais gagnée par
avance il faut être prudent mais je
crois que l'on peut être
particulièrement confiant il n'avait pas
répondu en seconde partie de ma question
la suite on verra bien on va faire les
élections les unes après les autres
je veux dire pour l'instant on est sur
les départementales et régionales et
quelques instants vous me disiez les
conditions de campagne sont
particulières là comme ailleurs puisque
pour présenter un journal qui est dans
les hauts de france il ya aussi des
candidats dans ce coin là on va d'abord
faire les élections régionales et puis
on verra ensuite comment on peut
organiser les suivantes
mais ça peut être une forme de primaires
ces élections régionales ou pas pour
vous pour vous ce sont deux élections
complètement différente sont des
élections parallèles puisque les uns son
candidat dans les hauts de france en
provence en rhône alpes ou en ile de
france donc on va déjà commencer par
j'allais dire transformer l'essai pour
les départementales et régionales
et puis après on pourra passer aux
présidentielles bon en attendant il ya
la crise sanitaire toujours julien oui
effet crise sanitaire qui nous occupe
beaucoup le premier ministre jean castex
a annoncé mardi la suspension des vols
entre le brésil et la france en raison
des inquiétudes liées invariants
émergents considérés comme plus
dangereux par les scientifiques
d'autres mesures sont attendues lundi
est ce que là encore on est très armés
pour répondre à ce genre d'inquiétude
falletti prend des décisions avant
fallait-il obligé par exemple les
passagers de retour du brésil au
confinement
c'est que ces constitutionnellement très
compliqué
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais y'a
tas de choses qui sont juridiquement
très compliqué mais enfin on est en état
de crise est en état de guerre pour
reprendre une expression du président de
la république donc ce qui est
dommageable c'est qu'il faille toujours
pointé du doigt exécutif pour qu'ils
prennent des mesures
ça a été le cas sur l'auto test il ya
quinze jours gouvernement ne voulait pas
se saisir les autotests alors que ça se
fait dans beaucoup d'autres pays
et puis on a fini par le faire en retard
dans la précipitation on a fini par le
faire parce que on a dit bon ben ok
c'est important et là on en commet de 52
millions notamment pour l'éducation
nationale et sur le brésil c'est pareil
on a attendu on a dit oui c'est
compliqué et ses appuis finalement tout
le monde a montré du doigt les
gens qui arrivent par milliers du brésil
et on a dit bon on va faire quelque
chose c'est toujours dans le doute et
sutout toujours sous la pression et le
gouvernement réagit est-ce que je pense
qu'il fallait le faire oui il fallait
faire mais est ce que c'est a cédé à la
question de la guyane qui se posent un
grand souvenir avec le brésil en guyane
le variant brésilien il est présent à
près de 90 + en est ce que il faut
prendre des mesures pour la guyane
mesure et suspendre les vols entre la
métropole et la guyane
en tous les cas il faut les filtres et
il faut veiller à ce qu'ils aient des
mesures sanitaires qui sont extrêmement
contrainte parce que il ya un variant
est un mutant qui est extrêmement
agressifs ont prétendu pas spécialiste
mais on prétend que il peut rendre
inoffensive certains vaccins et donc il
n'est pas question qu'on puisse
maintenant infesté la métropole avec un
vaurien qui vient comment aller loin
mais c'est marseille est ce que
concrètement il faut obliger à un
isolement à une quarantaine obligatoire
et je ne sais pas quel est le niveau
d'épidémie pour l'instant en guyane il
ya des risques très fort avec la
porosité de la frontière puisque mais
les présents à près de 90 rien brésil ça
veut dire on arrête les vols tant pis
pour la cour il faut et c'est la même
chose pour la continuité territoriale
entre régions métropolitaines vous
pouvez pas aller d'une région à l'autre
donc la guyane c'est une région
française il ya continuité territoriale
mais enfin sur le plan sanitaire il faut
bien mettre en place des contraintes
pour pas infesté le reste de la
population
autre question c'est hélas aujourd'hui
on devrait franchir le cap des cent
mille morts chiffre symbolique kong que
l'inserm d'ailleurs dit qu'on a dépassé
depuis y est depuis quelques temps on
peut importe chef de l'état devrait at
il selon vous s'exprimer pour rendre
hommage aux victimes et faudrait-il
organiser des commémorations un jour
particulier un lieu particulier oui je
pense qu'il faudra il faudra le faire
mais enfin on est à cent mille morts
malheureusement c'est pas fini donc la
pendule ne s'arrête pas aujourd'hui et
on va passer un cap un peu symbolique
cent mille morts mais
malheureusement je crains que y ait
d'autres morts après donc on va pas
s'arrêter sur ce chiffre malheureux des
cent mille morts il faudra attendre
quand même encore un petit peu pour
savoir où on en est la deuxième chose
c'est que ce qui est tragique c'est
qu'il ya une espèce d'un visibilisation
de ces morts parce que quand vous avez
des soldats qui meurent quand vous avez
des gens qui malheureusement succombe à
un attentat on voit leurs visages en
donnent leur nom là il ya quelque chose
d'anonymes c'est cent mille morts
globalement peut-être demain 110 120 150
et il faudra qu'un jour on fasse le
point et on sache
en gros au combien il ya une mort lee à
la coved
un hommage national un lieu qui a une
statue qui est un lieu de recueillement
et qu'on se souvienne quand même que
dans ce pays comme dans d'autres il ya
eu une crise une épidémie et qui a eu un
grand nombre de français qui d'autre
parce que des français qui ont succombé
à la co vide et il ya une forme de
mémoire qui devra se retrouver là pour
que les familles puissent avoir à les
yeux et qu' il ya une reconnaissance de
ce qui s'est passé mais dont il faut
attendre la fin de la de la fin de la
crise avant d'y songer
en tous les cas on peut il songé mais la
crise est malheureusement n'est pas
finie sur la vaccination le danemark
arrête sa vaccination avec astrazeneca
et il hier le gouvernement français lui
réitère sa confiance dans le vaccin est
ce qu il a raison au gouvernement à
écouter il ya des institutions
scientifiques qui sont là pour
conseiller le gouvernement
moi je ne peux que faire confiance à ces
institutions scientifiques
il ya eu des difficultés avec
astrazeneca qui au demeurant a changé de
nom paraît utile entre temps continue de
l'appeler astrazeneca
manque de pot mais il paraît qu'ils ont
quand même changé de nom en banc et puis
johnson & johnson avec le vaccin
j'enseigne également craint l'apparition
de caillot de sang alors est ce que
c'est quelque chose de rare qui justifie
qu'on puisse continuer visiblement c'est
ce que nous disent les institutions
scientifiques
donc faisons confiance aux institutions
scientifiques parce qu'on a besoin de
ces vaccins un mot sur le vaccinodromes
du stade de france parce qu'on avait le
maire de neuilly la semaine dernière
qu'ils nous disaient craindre que le
vaccinodromes du stade de france aspire
les doses lui dit ben moi je reçois
moins deux doses est ce que c'est une
crainte que vous partagez toute façon
depuis le début les vaccine au dôme
malheureusement amène la même difficulté
c'est-à-dire que vous prenez rendez vous
par exemple par l'intermédiaire de dr
libre vous pouvez prendre plusieurs
rendez vous et puis souvent les gens ils
ont un rendez-vous et préviennent pas
pour annuler les autres rendez vous
alors il ya moins de vaccins et en plus
il ya une espèce de petit cafouillage
autour des prises de rendez vous donc ça
donne lieu à des pertes
parce que souvent ce sont des vaccins
qu'on est obligé de jeter à la fin de la
journée
autre question d'actualité sur la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui le
le chef de l'état multiplie les
rencontres avec les avec les maires mais
aussi avec les ministres pour élaborer
une stratégie de réouverture la mission
d'information du sénat a préconisé une
réouverture des lieux culturels dès la
levée des mesures de restriction elle a
proposé à ce titre de rendre le pass
sanitaire obligatoire ce que vous y être
favorables moi je suis très très mesuré
sur l'histoire du pass sanitaire parce
que dans un pays comme la france qui est
très égalitaire on voit tout de suite la
difficulté on le voit en matière de
vaccins quand vous commencez à créer des
priorités on a commencé par dire c'est
les personnes d'un certain âge après on
a dit c'est des soignants a pressé les
enseignants maintenant on dit que c'est
les gars qui vont tenir les bureaux de
vote qui aurait d'ailleurs il va y avoir
que des prioritaires et ceux qui ne sont
pas ils se demandent pourquoi ils ne
sont pas dans une école vous avez les
professeurs et puis vous allez personnel
qui les a si ce qu'on appelle et les
atsem même bon et elles elles sont pas
prioritaires donc à force de créer des
priorités on sait plus vraiment qu'ils
les aient on n'a pas les vaccins
nécessaires pour suivre donc
moi je pense qu'il ya une difficulté et
donc assujettir l'ouverture de lieux
culturels passe sanitaires c'est quand
même problématique
autant en matière de transport ça peut
justifier et dans les règles
internationales ça existe parlé tout à
l'heure de la guyane on parle d'autres
voyages on peut assujettir la délivrance
d'un titre de transport à
impasse sanitaire parce que là vous
allez dans des pays étrangers où ils
allaient dans des pays lointains
même s'ils sont français ça peut se
justifier
autant dire vous pourrez aller au
restaurant vous pourrez aller au concert
uniquement si vous avez été vaccinés ou
si vous avez des anticorps presque avait
malheureusement eu la maladie il ya
quelques temps c'est quand même
compliqué vous créer deux sortes de
france ceux qui ont le droit parce
qu'ils ont été vaccinées c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit constitutionnellement
même pour vous ça pose voilà et je pense
que en france c'est très difficile
d'aller vers quelque chose de cette
nature
une question est qu une question et que
oui le ministère de l'économie
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
avait étalé ou annuler partiellement les
dettes d'entreprises au cas par cas est
ce que c'est une bonne initiative
oui je pense que c'est une bonne
initiative parce que vous avez encore
beaucoup de petites entreprises de tpe
de pme de commerçants qui sont pas très
bien identifiés par les services fiscaux
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de j'allais
dire de fiches d'information sur ces
entreprises et sur qui pèsent des
sujétions fiscale depuis deux ans parce
que 2020 beaucoup de ces entreprises
n'ont pas pu ouvrir 2021 on voit que
c'est laborieux et vous avez toujours
des dettes fiscales des dettes sociales
urssaf qui ont été reportés puis à
nouveau reporté au mois de mars et ont
dit on va étaler sa sur trois ans mais
si vous avez très peu travaillé qu'à la
fin de cette année on vous dit ah au
fait vous avez tout un tas de dead qui
date de 2020 plus 2021 et peu celle de
2022 vont arriver si le gouvernement ne
passe pas l'épongé
moi je sais pas comment ces entreprises
vont pouvoir survivre mort c'est un
tissu très important on sait très bien
que l'emploi dans ce pays ce sont
souvent les petites et moyennes
entreprises et aussi beaucoup de
commerces de tpe et je pense qu'il faut
injecter de l'argent en supprimant un
certain nombre de dettes sinon
c'est inouï à aller automne décès le
tissu local dans l'est dans les petites
villes en particulier on va parler de
l'actualité du sénat l'actualité cette
semaine c'était bien sûr le vote de la
loi séparatisme alors ça a parfois
divisé les centristes s'être séparatisme
notamment sur la question du voile est
ce que la droite sénatoriale est allé
trop loin je dirais que il ya une forme
d'expression à droite un peu vigoureuse
qui a pu indisposer certains mais
amicale circonvolutions certains êtres
si on voit des voiles partout
est ce bien raisonnable parce qu'après
c'est pas le tout de faire voter des
textes il faut pouvoir les appliquer moi
j'ai été maire pendant 20 ans je vois à
peu près comment ça se passe donc c'est
bien de dire il ya des textes mais vous
savez je pense que ceux qui veulent
vraiment faire du mal à la république
ils vont pas s'arrêter uniquement parce
qu'on aura voté malheureusement un texte
qui interdit de porter à voile devant
une école aux yeux de ces zooms bürki
donc c'est quoi c'est de l'affichage ces
mesures c'est pas applicable pour vous
il ya un côté symbolique on peut
comprendre et un côté symbolique on veut
afficher montré une volonté c'est
important quelquefois dans les débats ça
a pu gêner quelques-uns de mes amis qui
se demandaient où il était quoi donc
et vous aussi ça vous a gêné j'en ai vu
d'autres
donc pas s'arrêter à ça mais je comprend
l'affichage et je comprends la
symbolique montre une volonté
bon c'est vrai que dans le débat c'était
peut-être pas à 10 pour sa part fois de
la police et c'est de la politique
politicienne pour pour ou quand bruno
retailleau valoriste de ce discours là
puisque évidemment c'est lui qui est
aussi à la manoeuvre et qu'il est
candidat en plus à la présidentielle
vous le voyez comment une sorte de geste
pour affirmer sa une stature d'homme de
ferme à droite je crois que gérald
darmanin
à commencer à quantifier un débat avec
madame le pen et qui lui dit qu'elle est
un peu molle faut pas s'étonner que
certains essaient d'aller un peu plus
loin
wii que sur il ya une sous forme de
surenchère par une forme de surenchère
on voit bien que tout le monde veut
montrer qu'il est très volontariste
il faut respecter des règles qu'il faut
mettre un stop à un certain nombre de
pratiques
la difficulté c'est de savoir comment
justement on arrête ces pratiques et
donc c'est vrai que l'affichage et le
volontarisme qui est affichée parfois un
peu maladroit mais ma foi
le texte a quand même été votée
globalement et c'est là l'essentiel
un mot sur le référendum climat on en
parlait ça sera là le premier temps des
premiers textes examinés à la reprise
des travaux parlementaires
est ce que c'est un texte que vous
voterez ou est ce que pour vous la
rédaction de gouvernement n'est pas la
bonne sur le sur le référendum climat
sur la place tahrir dans la constitution
la préservation de dollars on peut pas
voter en l'état peut pas voter en l'état
le garde des sceaux lui-même a dit à
quelques semaines le verbe garantir oui
ça induit une obligation car ça veut
dire que vous obliger à réussir et à
partir de là aussi vous créez une
responsabilité pénale
donc ça veut dire que c'est un
référendum il n'aura pas lieu pour vous
ça dépend ce que voudrait faire le
président de la république sous cette
forme en tous les cas nous c'est non il
accepte votre vote rédaction soit n'en
soyez un compromis à l'est ou dans le
conte premier vous il faut demander ça
semblait parce que et voûté rennes on va
faire notre jeu on sent qu'on est quand
même toujours en ont au poker on attend
que l'autre fasse son mouvement et bien
non c'est non parce que eux ils ont ils
ont ils ont voté un texte qui est né de
la fameuse convention citoyenne louis
bien sûr
qui sait tout puisque c'est qu'il aurait
écrit nous on nous dit voilà sans filtre
bon c'est le président le président qui
l'a acceptée alors les gars ils écrivent
garantir et d'où il faudrait qu'on dise
ah bah oui aux garanties non ben non
garantis pas et donc on renvoie le plat
en mettant
autre chose favorise d'ailleurs nicolas
hulot quand il était ministre avait fait
voter en 2018 avec le vert favorise et
ça a été voté à l'assemblée nationale
donc là il ya le verbe garantir nous
nous pensons que c'est trop fort
d'ailleurs le conseil d'état l'a dit
ça a été confirmé par le garde des
sceaux donc c'est une responsabilité
trop lourde
un mot sur la réforme de la justice oui
autre actu qui qui concerne le garde des
sceaux eric dupond moretti qui a
présenté hier donc en conseil des
ministres la réforme de la justice avec
une mesure qui fait beaucoup réagir le
monde des magistrats et des avocats
c'est celui de la mesure d'écarter les
jurés populaires des audiences pour les
crimes passibles de 15 à 20 ans de
réclusion
est ce que c'est une bonne idée selon
vous non je crois pas je crois que on
peut pas faire deux choses à la fois de
façon contraire sérénac convient de le
dire on crée des conventions citoyenne
tout bout de champ on veut de la
démocratie directe présent la république
va consulter les maires au fin fond des
villages pour savoir s'ils sont prêts à
faire des élections
et puis là on dit il ya des citoyens
mais on va les retirer parce que vous
comprenez ça permettra d'aller plus vite
bon soit on veut que la justice soit
populaire elle est rendue au nom du
peuple français et les citoyens sont
présents et
on les retire pour des raisons
techniques et de rapidité moi je pense
que c'est une mauvaise chose
défiez les oligarques sg mois filmer les
audiences c'est une autre des réformes
qui est contenue dans le projet
on a l'habitude ici on est au sénat
assemblée nationale on est filmé alors
c'est à la fois la transparence et
pourquoi pas en même temps il faudrait
pas que ça induisent un certain nombre
de posture de la part de certains
avocats de certains ils n'ont pas besoin
de caméras pour faire des postures c'est
oui oui non mais allez moi je dirais que
c'est pas mauvais que il est la
transparence et que les caméras rentrer
dans les voyages faut être prudent vous
savez pas encore ce que vous faites trop
c'est trop tôt
on va regarder le texte d'un will et
j'attends variés et donc merci merci
beaucoup regardent la une de la voix du
nord
pollution de l'air des milliers morts
évitées c'est à la une de la voix du
nord eric dupond-moretti aussi un homme
du nom la réforme de la justice comme
eric dupond-moretti font débat c'est à
la une de la voix du nord merci
messieurs
[Musique]